mais il est ici pour visiter les locaux
de la nouvelle clinique d'infirmière qui
ouvre dès lundi alors on va venir trois
infirmières vont recevoir et traiter ici
des cas non urgent référés par l'urgence
de la Cité de la santé de Laval si on
parle de 250 à 300 rendez-vous par
semaine alors qu'ici la cité de Laval on
fait à peu près 3000 rendez-vous
d'urgence dès qu'on parle de 10 à 15%
qu'on est capable d'enlever des urgences
pour le faire au bon endroit et parce
qu'elle est dans l'université cette
clinique sera aussi un lieu de formation
pour les futurs infirmières c'est la
première fois que ça va faire vraiment
que l'Université de Montréal va utiliser
ses locaux au service d'un 6 d'un
organisation de santé alors moi je suis
très fière de ça à la communauté pour
essayer de dégager un peu le réseau de
toute la pression qui pèse sur lui et en
même temps on fait la formation pour
pour nos étudiantes nos étudiants
sciences infirmières et tout accélérer
la formation des infirmières
praticiennes spécialisées ont compte
actuellement 11 ans de ces infirmières
au Québec l'objectif est d'informer 902
plus d'ici trois ans
ici est idéal et les étudiants et
étudiants vont contribuer au service
offert les stagiaires vont voir les
patients ils vont évaluer les patients
pour décider diagnostics plan de
traitement et vous retourner voir
l'infirmière par la suite et ensemble
ils vont décider si le plan traitement
qui avait été décidé était acceptable
une formation pratique dans un
environnement dernier cri un élément de
plus pour séduire d'éventuelles
candidats à la profession d'infirmière
c'est un plus c'est directement dans
notre campus ça nous permet d'aller à
nos cours après devenir en stage en
soirée ici David gentil les radios
Canada Laval